Ah, ah.
Welcome back, Master.
Hello, hello, hello.
I can't decide.
I was trying to go for a sneaking suit style, but I feel that...
Wait, wait, wait.
The music will get so loud.
Hold on.
I want to talk more before we watch this.
Hold on!
Oh, there we go.
I can't decide if I want to have dark hair only.
I can't decide.
Nah, we'll go with this.
We'll go with sneaking suit version.
Sneaking maid version.
Full dark?
Yeah, yeah.
I also couldn't tell if I go with my normal hair.
My normal hair, I feel like kind of...
OK, this might be my Delulu speaking.
But I kind of look like Boss.
OK, but you have to see...
OK, hold on.
I'm going to put myself right next to him.
He's going to go... OK, hold on.
You have to understand.
Hold on.
Look, look, look.
He's going to show up any second now.
Oh Big Boss!
Oh there he is!
See, I kind of look like him.
Oh my God!
Pacific Ocean!
Oh my God, that's going to be us.
Yeah, my favorite useless character!
Yeah, Strangelove!
My favorite dumb name!
Oh my God, that's going to be us.
Oh my God.
BGM is so good.
I also... Did I do my intro?
I can't remember.
Sorry, I'm too excited.
What I wanted to say though is that I love this menu here.
I feel like it really sets the tone of how Peace Walker is.
It's kind of spooky.
It's mysterious.
It's a little dark.
It's like...
But...
It's so good.
The 70s.
Yeah.
I pressed the start button.
I wonder if it worked.
Nope.
Peace amongst men living alongside one another is not a natural state.
On the contrary, the natural state of man is that of war.
I can't read fast.
Amongst.
I do want to say...
Obviously, no spoilers.
I feel this game has many, many spoilers.
Yeah!
Watch it one more time!
One more time!
I love you, Pies!
I love you so much!
I'll never... Nobody can make you hate... Wait.
Nobody can ever make me hate you.
I love you, Pies.
I love you the mostest ever.
Oh, Cecile!
The girl who literally said...
I don't know what the heck you guys are doing here and I'm not involved anymore.
She's so... She's...
That little skip.
She literally says...
I'm out.
I have nothing to do with this.
And never...
It's never heard from again.
Can I get a birthday from my totally not Oshie?
If you're gonna say it like that...
I mean...
You don't sound very appreciative of my birthday.
But I guess I'll sing happy birthday for you.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear fool!
Happy birthday!
Sorry, I feel like my brain is all over the place.
Because I didn't stream yesterday and I'm all like...
If you're like BB, does that mean you'll be in a speedo?
If I'm lucky.
Is your sync okay?
Yeah, I have to talk about that.
Basically, my sync broke and I can't use it.
Basically, right now it overflows.
It does not drain the water.
And the dish drainer stops working.
Or the disposal thing.
The thing that goes...
And gets rid of all the food.
And when it does start to drain, it leaks all over.
Yeah, and they actually have come to fix this before.
And so, now they have to do it again.
Go away Xbox!
So, it's so annoying.
And it smells really bad and I'm upset about it.
But I put in like a maintenance thing.
And I was like, okay, someone will come to the maid cafe today.
For sure.
And I checked yesterday and I was like, it definitely says that they're gonna come to the maid cafe.
And then I checked this morning because they did not come to the maid cafe.
And I checked this morning and it was gone!
So I have to...
I have to do it again.
I can't wash my dishes.
Dishes.
So they didn't show up yesterday at all?
Nope!
That was a big old waste of my time.
Wash them in the toilet.
Such a good idea.
Hope co-op works for you.
Xbox is giving me problems.
Really?
I saw some people...
So, for anybody who's just like, why is she doing the Xbox over the PlayStation?
I decided because, you know...
Previously I've seen other Vtubers play Peace Walker and it was on the PlayStation.
And I thought, you know, not everybody maybe still has a PS3.
And also you can still technically buy this on the Xbox.
So...
I was like, you know, we'll just switch it up a little bit.
And...
But...
Sorry, I almost spilled my water.
But, if it...
If...
Maybe less people show up for this one instead?
Well, we can always switch back.
I don't know.
Honestly, it's been something that's been like...
Been like in my brain because so many people are...
Conflicting things and are just like, oh, I wish you were playing on this one instead.
But, I can't please everybody.
I'm sorry.
I can only do one or the other.
So, I'm sorry, okay?
Yes, so, I'm doing my best out here, please.
Jester, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Jester.
Happy birthday!
If you're a dog, I hope you're not drinking.
21 years is really old for dog years.
I can't believe the streamer isn't playing on PlayStation, Xbox and PSP simultaneously.
I know!
Can you believe it?
She's falling off.
We can play the other next year.
Why?
No!
Please play on PSP.
Bust out my...
I've had to do that though.
I had to finagle a situation for portable ops before.
Anyway, let's see.
This is gonna be weird though, because...
What if I made it really small?
This is gonna be weird playing.
It's my first time playing a Metal Gear game on Xbox.
So, I'm kind of scared about the controls, I'm not gonna lie.
We'll see though.
Press A to apply.
Oh gosh, why?
OK.
We'll do here?
That's good.
Oh,
I think I was testing it.
New game!
Let's go.
I'm not gonna have all my stuff.
It's gonna be so sad.
Birthday was 6 days ago.
I know it's a bit late, but what if I told you I'm now 27 years old.
Solid Snake in Metal Gear 2 Zanzibar Land.
Rodan, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Rodan, Zanzibar Land.
Happy birthday!
I did mention earlier.
No spoilers, because this game has a lot of cool story stuff.
Recently... Oh my gosh, you guys.
Recently, I've been seeing some Peace Walker slander on my timeline on Twitter.
And it's making... I'm like...
I'm like, excuse me?
Of all the things.
Peace Walker!
I don't understand.
I saw there was one post that I saw.
That showed up in my For You page or whatever.
That was like...
It was like a video.
It was a screenshot of a video.
I guess a video or a short, whatever, on YouTube.
And someone commenting being like...
Hey, you didn't include Peace Walker in this list.
I don't know what the video was.
But then the person who made the video responded and said...
Yeah, because I only included games that were a part of the canon.
And I'm like...
Huh?
What are you talking about?
How is this game...
How do you play Five without Peace Walker?
I saw that too.
Yeah, I think it probably showed up in some people's...
I get a bunch of Metal Gear posts.
So if I get them and you also like Metal Gear stuff, you probably see them too.
Five literally follows Peace Walker.
I don't understand the logic.
I feel like Peace Walker is honestly Metal Gear Solid 5.
It wasn't supposed to be, technically.
But it's like the limitations of PSP...
Metal Gear fans are so silly.
Did they confuse it with Poops?
I don't know.
Maybe.
Maybe really.
Those PSP games, they're all the same, right?
Those PSP games.
It is.
MGSV is V, not 5.
Oh yeah, I switch between saying V and 5 all the time.
Fans as silly as the series.
I know, right?
Why does this game offer a Monster Hunter Control Type?
That's... You'll see!
Yeah, we have to select Shooter Type, Action Type.
Similar to that of MGS4.
Of course, we're going to go with Monster Hunter Type.
No, I'm just kidding.
How would...
Yeah, Shooter Type.
What is the Hunter Type anyway?
Move.
Reset Camera.
Select Item.
Right Trigger is just not used.
Select Weapon.
Oh, I thought... Oh gosh.
Auto Aim Switch.
Display Menu.
Crouch.
How is it so different?
Melee Attack.
Or Auto Aim.
And that... Oh my goodness, actually there's so much.
Auto Aim Switch.
You can press either X or...
Wait, what's Melee Attack here then?
How do I CQC?
Oh, R.
RT, RT.
Interesting.
So a piece walked on this phantom day.
Yeah, pretty much.
This is so strange.
But also it's Aim Weapon or Attack.
And then also...
Melee Attack or Cancel Aim.
I guess for anybody playing Monster Hunter Wilds...
You might want to choose the Hunter type, perhaps.
I have Monster Hunter Wilds.
Actually, I got sent a...
I don't know if you guys saw...
If you guys saw Doki Birds.
She posted like a box that she got from Capcom.
I got the same thing, I just have to set it up and make it look nice and take a picture.
Oh my gosh, it's so cool.
It's probably... Well, not to say that I've gotten any PR packages.
I've only... Actually, this is only my second one.
But I feel like it will probably be the coolest one I've ever had.
It's actually right next to my computer right now, so I can look at it.
It's a real like...
It's like a real wooden box.
I don't know if you can hear it.
It's like a big wooden crate, almost.
And then...
It has... It came with a jacket.
Like a really nice fleece lined...
Like... Hold on, what does it say on it?
I gotta get it.
Oh my god, it's so heavy.
It says...
Forbidden Lands Expedition Team.
Hold on.
And it came with a plushie.
And it came with like some little cards.
That show like the different units.
Or characters from the units.
So it has like the Palico, and Gemma, and Alma.
I don't know those characters, I'm sorry.
And then...
It also came with like this big...
Like, oh my gosh, if I was a LARPer, if I were a LARPer, this would be like a dream come true for me.
It came with like a little necklace.
I don't know if you can hear that.
It came with like a... It looks... It's kind of like a...
What do you say?
Clay?
It seems so rustic.
And then...
A big like leather bound book.
And all the pages.
All the pages.
Is it white stone?
Yes, yes, it's a white stone.
It's a white stone.
And then like a big book.
That is actually like a book.
I'll have to take pictures of it later.
Like, the book has like pages that I could write in.
Like, again, if I were a LARPer, I would be the happiest person ever.
And it also came with...
It came with so much stuff.
I'm also kind of like, where do I put all this?
It came with a little leather pouch.
Did I have any... And...
I think... I think this is...
Oh, yeah, it just has a...
It came with a little leather pouch.
And it also came with a tapestry.
That says Mint Phantom on it.
So it's like crazy.
It's so... I will take a picture of it.
Personalized?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's personalized.
I was so excited when I got the email.
I was like, yo!
So now I have an Ace Attorney... Ace Attorney gavel with my name on it.
Now I have a Monster Hunter tapestry with my name on it.
I was like, Capcom loves me or something.
Oh my gosh, thank you, Capcom.
Not spon...
Well, this, I guess... Sponsored?
Not really.
Yeah, it's so cool though.
I was happy.
I think I saw a couple... I think Snuffy got one too.
Maybe Limel?
I know Limel got a... She had like a stream.
She got like a Monster Hunter outfit, which is so cool.
Anyway, sorry, I'm done napping.
Not action type.
Shooter type.
Whatever.
Not sponsored, but loved by.
Maybe.
Like I said, I gotta take a nice picture of it.
The year was 1964.
The world was firmly in the grip of the Cold War, divided into East and West.
One of America's heroes had defected to the Soviet Union.
The Boss.
She was known as the Boss, the mother of the Special Forces, and the soldier said to have led the Allies to victory in World War II.
However, the American-made miniature nuclear warhead she took with her was used to destroy a Soviet research facility.
Bogan.
Facing full-scale nuclear war, the leaders of the world's superpowers held top-secret talks to avert Armageddon.
The Soviet Union wanted assurance that this was not the work of Uncle Sam.
They wanted America to eliminate one of the most legendary soldiers.
The Boss.
The person assigned this mission was her closest apprentice, the soldier known as Snake.
Snake made the anguished journey into enemy territory, eventually confronting and killing the Boss at a fortress called Groznygrad, proving America's innocence in avoiding nuclear or something something.
Having saved the world, Snake was hailed a true hero and given the title, Big Boss.
Following the award ceremony, however, Snake disappeared.
Yeah, he left those fake-ass people.
He said, nah, I don't want anything to do with it.
Oh my god.
There better not be some men on the beach.
I might lose it.
We're in Columbia.
Whisper Randolph.
It's raining.
Soldiers without borders!
MSF!
Mitos without borders.
Sorry, I was blocking the date.
It was November 4th, 1974.
1974.
Men on the beach!
I love Top Gun!
This camera, this shaking cam is going nutso right now.
That's me too when I say I'm Boss!
Boss!
White day is over, today is fight day.
Free control time.
Oh my god, I clipped so much into him.
I'll let you go.
I'll let you go, little guy.
This is us waiting for Mito to escape.
Show them how it's done, Boss!
Ok!
I don't...
I am!
Why?
I don't take orders from anybody!
Such a silly tutorial.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
Thanks for that, Boss.
They're not as...
Oh no, I was ready, I'm sorry!
You're on the right!
They're not as obedient or like as...
Grateful, that's the word.
As they are...
In...
Finally!
Oh, crouch a lot.
It's like real combat training.
Yes sir!
It's such a strange thing to get used to though.
I'm moving while I'm crouching.
I'm holding it down.
Good!
No more, no more humping the ground.
Be careful!
Good!
Woohoo!
Again!
I got that!
Don't forget it!
Oh, I can't touch them.
Wait, wait.
Stand up.
Oh, there we go.
That's it!
No, I would never.
OK Repeatedly!
Is that guy you too?
Come on!
Yep, I'm the best ever doing it.
A million?
Or dead?
Yeah, it's raining.
He would have died.
This guy is so ready.
Good acting!
OK, Mr. Krabs over here.
They are like, make boss feel really good about himself, OK?
Oh!
Yeah!
I love doing that!
Throwing!
Oh my God!
Thank you!
He said he's dead!
I'm ready boss!
In a neurotic way?
OK Alright!
Go!
I'm ready boss!
Wait,
what am I doing?
Oh, OK Come here baby!
Thank you!
That's when you do the Russian twine.
OK
Oh gosh, I have to aim now too?
Again!
I'm ready boss!
Come here!
Oh, whoopsie.
I messed up.
Sorry!
Come here!
Oh, I can't aim!
Wake up!
I'm trying!
But I can't aim!
There we go
I can't aim!
Everybody...everybody steps forward When you're surrounded by multiple enemies, you'll have to take them on one after the other.
Steven Seagal did fake karate
Alright, everybody...I'm ready boss!
What am I doing?
Oh, OK
Oh, next!
There we go.
Oh, we're doing our little sequence.
OK I did it!
I did it!
Oh, you have to do it with all three.
Oh, no flipping.
OK, OK, OK Next Next
Good?
Yippee!
Oh, everybody's got to get their shot Oh, dammit Wake up!
Next!
Boss, press the attack button when the icon appears
Blue eyes and bows?
I don't have to have blue eyes
Snake!
Look at him brooding.
This man believes in Santa Claus Snake!
Snake!
Oh my God, you guys are gonna...you guys are gonna love Kazuhiro Miller Oh my God, you guys are gonna love him if you don't know him yet Ah, you're gonna love Kaz Boss
Vic Boss!
I love the art in this game so much What's the artist's name?
Ashley?
Ashley Wood.
Yes, thank you.
I thought it was Wood, but I didn't want to be wrong
Oh my God, see?
Yummy
Peace Galvez Galvez Rocket Peace
He's just smiling The army as a permanent institution is abolished.
The peace constitution.
Best girl, best girl!
Yeah, Spike Spiegel.
No, no, they don't appear to be guerillas.
They're far too organized.
What's your government's take?
The authorities in San Jose claim it's a multinational security firm.
Hired by the Development Corporation of Costa Rica.
Lies, obviously.
They're bringing in state-of-the-art weaponry and equipment by the shipload.
Where'd they get that kind of cash?
I fear La Silla may be...
La Silla!
The CIA.
As you both know, the United States views Central America as its backyard.
Even after Cuba, we've managed to maintain a delicate balance with the U.S.
And your government can't just give them the boot?
We are not allowed to bear arms.
Oh no, they have no bear arms.
Japan's constitution has something similar.
Article 9.
It says Japan renounces war and can't maintain an army.
I understand that you and your men have neither state nor ideology.
That you will fight any foe.
Please, you must drive them out of our defenseless country.
We come to you, the Militaire Sans Frontieres.
Militaire Sans Frontieres.
Yes, as our deterrent.
We can't afford to pay much, it's true.
But...
We can offer you this.
Yeah, baby!
An offshore plant in the Caribbean.
It's home!
Sounds pretty good to me.
This place is becoming a mess anyway.
Snake, we need some place we can settle down.
He wants to be a housewife.
Unofficially, of course.
A shopper for transport would be nice too.
Snake, I want to settle down now.
Come on!
You seem to think we are just a pack of dogs of war.
Is that right?
He wants to settle down.
You are an army without a state.
No, we've only left our countries behind.
Please, you must help us.
If your suspicions are true, force isn't going to do any good.
You'll have to find a political solution.
The government's hands are tied.
Go back to your bosses in San Jose.
Tell them what they want, I'll introduce them to a negotiator I know.
No, I'm not here on their behalf.
So, what are you doing here?
For over 20 years, I've preached the virtues of peace at multiple universities.
Tonight, I stand before you as an educator.
She's so cute!
She came to me to study peace.
Her name is Paz.
Paz Ortega.
Paz Ortega, I love you!
Paz.
Peace.
I love you so much.
I love you.
No kidding.
That's my name too.
No, you're Kaz.
I love this Golden Retriever boy.
Paz.
Call me Kaz.
Paz stumbled upon that facility while searching for a lost friend.
Rizla's Kaz.
She's only a child.
16 years old.
They did terrible things to her.
But somehow she managed to escape.
Thank God.
She's so cute!
Her mother died when she was small.
Thank you Kojima.
Hideo Kojima, everybody.
She hates war with a passion like no other.
My name is Paz.
And I will do anything to protect my namesake.
It is my one and only purpose.
Please, get them out of my country.
Make them leave Costa Rica.
Sorry kid, we know who you are, big boss.
That is why we've come to you.
Prologue in Army.
I love this game so much.
Even with how serious it is, it's still so silly.
It's like, it's the last game to be so silly.
At the same time, you know.
Hello!
Ok.
Bye.
I will.
They are really adamant about that.
They're like, hey, you know...
This beach looks so familiar.
Like we're gonna have some...
Some dates here.
Wait, can I?
Is there a first person?
That's what I'm doing!
A coconut?
LB.
Ok.
Oh my god!
We get it!
Guys, please!
Holy moly.
Guy won't shut up.
Ok.
I would never.
I would never do that.
What are you talking about?
You can't crawl though.
Ok!
My depth perception.
What do you want me to do, huh?
Don't you think you could hear...
What are you saying?
I'm bad?
I literally just double headshot these dummies.
I got the coconut.
Oh wow, there's even more stuff.
Backseater energy.
I know!
Come on!
I've played these games before!
It is good to kind of get used to this again.
What is this one?
Oh, surround indicator.
And we got ration.
Yeah, I forgot there's no...
This game is back to having no radar, unfortunately.
Getting used to the Xbox controller.
I know!
Gosh.
My stun rod.
Says the guy who just told me that I need to practice more.
For sure.
Whatever.
Wait, does the ration also...
So for this game, for those who don't know, this game you have to like...
It's one of those types of games where you have an R&D department and you have to...
Make all your weapons and all your things like that.
So when I find stuff, I want to loot it even more.
So weird to hear this in Xbox controller.
They had to have recorded new voice lines for that.
I know, it's kind of interesting, right?
We get a new experience.
It's kind of fun.
Let's go.
Man, am I glad to be out of here.
Finally, we can leave all that crap in San Geronimo behind.
Geronimo!
Break into the mercenary business for real.
Let me guess.
You're doing it for her.
For Geronimo.
Our trauma.
Trauma flashback.
Do it for her.
Do it for her!
Kaz looks so cute in her Little Nightmares cosplay.
Will someone please light this man cigar?
Someone please.
I love how much Kaz looks like a Ken doll in this game.
Yeah.
The peace management evolution.
And portable Ops Peace Rocker would be kind of cool.
Yeah!
They only got better at the system, which is cool to see.
La Silla!
Don't leave him in the rain.
Dang, Boss got smart.
He's always been smart.
But like him a way, you know?
Tree frogs or bridges?
That's just a code name the CIA made up.
We are not close like that.
Gosh.
Excuse you.
John Metal Gear.
Hot.
It's already...
Not the backyard!
Where will we go out to play?
Where will we put our swing set?
No!
What do we do with the grill?
No more barbecues.
Is America not already split into North and South?
Is that...
Oh my God.
The detail on Florida looks so funny.
Time to split it more.
Sorry for...sometimes the audio skips a little.
What?
Why?
I haven't noticed.
Maybe it's me.
Oh my God, I look like Big Boss right now.
I'm the one saying that.
Ooh.
Because she's cute.
I don't know.
Tape 69.
Uh oh.
Ah yeah, product placement.
This is the third time that Kaz has mentioned Japan.
I'll just let you guys know.
A pretzel?
Yes, the pretzel.
She's a horse girl.
What?
What's it going to be?
Loyalty to your country or loyalty to me?
Your country or your mentor?
Your mission or your beliefs?
Ooh, my heart.
No spoilers everyone.
Oh my gosh.
My little finger.
No!
Yeah, for Paz.
Do it for her.
Peace!
Look how cute she is.
She's so precious.
Yeah, we're doing it for her.
For Paz.
For peace.
November 10th, 1974.
Who the hell?
The blindest man ever.
Blind.
I'm right here.
Okay, time to finally get into it, huh?
Time to finally...
Take the long way around.
Whatever it takes to stay out of sight.
Your gun is a last resort.
I didn't realize that my gun was a CQC gun.
I didn't realize.
I didn't realize that I didn't have a CQC gun on me.
Look how fast it goes down.
They're like hey you're in the tutorial so don't worry about it.
This is HQ.
To press up against the wall, face it and hit the action button.
From that position, you can press LT to detect enemies.
That also works while lying down.
I forgot...
This is HQ.
This is patrol.
All clear!
Yep, all clear!
Stay vigilant.
The indicator in the upper right serves as a compass.
Everybody is talking.
I can't pay attention at all.
Where was I going?
Oh my god, please guys.
I can't pay attention.
The more easily you'll be spotted.
Conspicuous movements and loud noises will compromise your camo index.
Your fatigues will act as camouflage.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
Holy...
Oops.
I don't remember how to zoom in.
But it's okay right now.
I think we're alright.
We're in the tutorial.
It's fine.
Give me a...
Bye!
There is no zoom?
Maybe.
Other weapons.
I can't zoom in yet.
Tutorial jitters.
I literally didn't notice that I was holding the big gun.
I was gonna go take him down.
I was!
I promise!
Oh my gosh, I forgot that this also has...
Oops.
This also has the...
What do you call it?
The... You...
You... You're...
Oh, I'm blocking... Hold on.
I'm blocking a lot of stuff.
So let me scoot over just a little bit.
I'll make myself smaller too.
The suppressor!
It'll... It'll break eventually.
The love box.
Not yet, unfortunately.
I'm not using...
Oh yeah, and we're also regaining health.
Gotta remember how this game works.
Gotta get used to it.
You think I can get that guy?
You think I can do the greatest shot of all time?
You think I can do it?
Oh, I got him.
I got him?
Nah.
I still got him.
I still got him though.
Looks like you're inside the compound.
Security is tight.
Stay sharp.
Just gonna...
Oh, that one was bad.
Uh-oh, my suppressor!
Uh-oh.
We're... We're donezo.
It's all over for us.
Time to sunrod.
Or, we could just explode everything.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Oh my god, there's a guy over there too.
I'm remembering how to play the game.
Kind of.
I'm remembering.
The hello... sudden Kojima mention.
My suppressor.
This is why we do the ops at night.
I know, right?
What are we doing?
What are we thinking here?
I can't tell where the other guy is.
The guy that's supposed to be on... Oh, I see him now.
That's right.
Hold on.
We're good.
Don't worry about it.
I wish I could've...
I wish I could've taken him out for real though.
Yeah, beat that guy's butt.
Okay, this guy doesn't go any further.
I don't know how he heard me.
Hello.
Start talking?
You're looking for a two-story building to the east.
Okay.
Two-story building to the east.
Is this a two-story building?
Or...
I'm working on it, guys.
Gosh, he's so impatient.
Oh, I need the better equipment.
Yes sir, we broke him.
We acquired the whereabouts of target 500.
Acknowledged.
Spears are loaded.
The barge is clear to point Bravo.
Acknowledged.
Out.
Katsune Miku Oh, Archie!
Sorry.
Why...
I didn't notice at all.
Irizu
Oh I'm hungry.
I forgot there is... Archie!
What the heck is that?
Forgot about the QTEs.
He gets so into the cutscenes.
Shiny.
Actually, it would.
Actually, I recently got a...
A...
It's got a circuit that reverses the audio phase.
A comic book of MGS1 with art from Ashley Lynn.
I found it.
Found it.
Britney?
Oh baby, baby.
Oh.
Just kidding.
Yeah!
Not to the nukes.
Metal Gear Solid Peace Walker!
Oh my gosh.
It's been so long since we heard this.
Wah!
Alert phases 1.
Don't worry about it.
Obtained design specs for the following weapon.
Oh the M1C.
Rank 1.
Very cool.
Sandinistas.
If only I hadn't gotten that alert.
Or gotten an S rank maybe.
Nuke.
Japan Mansion!
Don't do a Japan drinking game with me.
I think you'll die.
Are they planning a test?
Showing off?
Or is it all to keep the anti-American movement in check?
Good question.
Why bring them here?
I can't figure it out.
Whatever the CIA is up to in Costa Rica, the professor wants it stopped.
We need to find out what that something is.
We need to get ready for this task.
Repairs.
Working as fast as we can boss.
This place is pretty beat.
Looks like hell.
But as long as you're with us, we'll make it heaven.
No one can bother us here.
No state telling us what to do.
This is the MSF's haven.
Our mother base.
Mother base!
We'll back you up even better than before.
We're gonna turn this pile of junk into something big.
Our mother base baby!
There was a... I went to Enoshima in Japan, right?
Look how cute she is.
I went to Enoshima in Japan and...
There was a... It's a little island and... If you don't know what it is...
It's a little island and there's a shrine... A couple shrines there and stuff and it's just...
It's like a really popular... Well, it's a really popular date spot.
But it's also a really popular spot for like...
For like school kids to go.
For like trips and stuff.
In Japan.
And there's like a beach area.
Obviously, because it's an island.
But I was on the beach and there was like a boat way, way in the distance.
And I was like...
That's it!
That's mother base!
They're coming to pick me up!
I'm going up!
Totally my portable oil rig mother base boat.
Yeah, Minto getting folded.
Also, the tattoo!
Contemplating what kind of tattoo you might want.
Would you ever consider an Ashley Woods rendition of Snake?
As cool as that would be, I think I would want something a little bit more subtle.
Like, honestly, even like the peace...
Like, I think it would be cheesy for anyone else that doesn't know Metal Gear.
But like the peace symbol from this game.
How it has like the plane.
As like the little parts inside or something.
Something a little bit more...
That was kind of cheesy though, no?
Maybe the peace symbol is a little cheesy.
But...
The logo is pretty clean.
Anyone else would be like, oh wow, this girl is a hippie.
But I've also thought about, of course, like the foxhound logo.
Because...
You know, like how Meryl has it.
But I once made temporary tattoos of it.
I don't know though.
I would want something really subtle.
So I could always look at it and be like, Metal Gear.
But also, like, I don't want like a sleeve or anything.
I feel like if I were to get Ashley Wood's art of Snake, it would have to be like humongous, no?
For like all the small details to really...
Get it all on my back.
Get a full back...
Full back tat of Snake's face.
It would be like he's sneaking up on me.
You can buy offshore oil rigs.
They auction them off and they're not as expensive as you might think.
I know!
I've been told this before.
And...
You know...
I wonder what the maintenance is like on that.
How do you even...
Take care of it?
Outer Heaven tattoo would go hard.
Outer Heaven?
Outer Heaven.
The skull one with the snake in it?
Or Outer Haven?
Wait.
Outer Heaven.
Which...
Outer...
Heaven...
Logo.
Oh, that's the skull with the...
With the wings, that's right.
Outer Haven is the skull with the snake.
Tattoo of an exclamation mark.
Outer Haven is Sideview Skull.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Welcome to MSF's Mother Base!
Mother Base can support your mission in many different ways, from developing new weapons to collecting intelligence.
Exclamation mark.
Maybe...
Somewhere.
For me, placement is a really big thing too.
Get a tattoo of Snake's back...
With his arm around your neck so you can pretend he's holding you.
He's so juicy.
I'll have like... I'll get like a little knife on my neck so it's like he's holding the knife to my neck.
And I'll be like...
Start talking.
Look at our people!
Would you like to view the staff assignments?
Yeah, it's been a while so we'll do that.
Mother Base is divided into several...
Actually, I think I remember pretty well.
Yeah, nevermind.
I remember.
Yeah, yeah, I remember.
This concludes the tutorial.
Look at him!
Wait, details.
We're not mercenaries.
We're not a foreign legion.
MSF's a business.
A new kind of business.
Kazuhiro's all about that dollar-dollar bill, baby.
This guy, he even was just like...
Even when we started the mission, he was just like, Finally, we're not gonna be just a place where some guys chill.
We're finally making some money, baby.
Oh my gosh, I wonder what guys we have.
We have Eagle Ray.
I'm a slave to fashion.
I collect T-shirts in my spare time.
I love the names of the guys in here.
They're so funny.
Let's put our heads together and make Mother Brace grow.
Alright, Cabbage White.
Hikari.
I'm no good with people.
Please look after me.
Ostrich.
I got a buddy named Johnny!
You know him?
Frill Shark.
I got a daughter back home.
Haven't seen her in years.
Bobcat.
Nothing like pumping some iron.
Alligator.
It's an honor to serve under a hero like you.
Lobster.
My grandpa was a mechanic.
I can take an air-cooled engine apart in five minutes flat.
Bluegill.
Take a look at these guys.
I was the arm-wrestling champion of my hometown.
Two years running.
And runner-up the year before that.
The champion before that!
Okay, Bluegill.
Your stat isn't that high.
Magpie.
You stay here too long, you start losing track of what day it is.
Rhinoceros.
My wife is always good to me.
I guess that's what love is.
Mun-ra-si...
That's a death flag.
I left some of my buddies behind on the last battlefield.
You gonna give me the chance to make it up to them here?
No!
Your stats are doo-doo!
I'm gonna send you overboard!
Lungfish.
I'm a weapons technician.
It literally says you are a medic.
Scissor.
It says you are a medic.
You say weapons kill people?
I say they are needed to protect people.
Koi-poo.
I'm your man.
Give me an order and it'll get done.
As long as it's nothing to do with R&D because you have no skill.
Bobcat doesn't know he's joined a mercenary group.
Bobcat just thinks this is the best gym.
I was about to be like, wow, who's this talented fella?
Alright, let's see.
We're gonna put you guys...
I almost feel like auto-assigning.
Wait, how do I do that?
Put you in R&D.
We gotta start making money!
We gotta start making our GMP!
Our...
Good...
Mental points.
Auto-assign is pretty good in this.
How do I do it again?
Is it...
No?
In the jail.
No...
Master Miller's good.
Go down?
Oh, thank you!
Auto-assign.
Sniper rifle!
Throwing weapons.
Smoke grenade.
We'll be able to make a full 10 soon.
Versus.
And then R&D.
This is where we get our stuff.
No, I think I'm okay.
I think I remember.
I think it's not so difficult.
Yeah, yeah, I remember.
We can...
When we... It's like a tree, no?
Oh, we do have money!
I will be using this a lot.
So...
Let's start working on that.
And...
Sniper rifle.
Start working on that.
What's this?
Smoke grenade.
We'll start working on that.
Okay.
Cool, cool.
And what items?
We probably don't have anything.
Oh!
Fulton!
Analyzer?
What is this?
Love box!
Everybody, this is the most important thing.
If you get anything out of this game, remember the love box.
What's this?
Analyzer.
Analyzer's information about enemies.
Oh, that's right!
We can see if they're worth stealing or not.
But for right now, we need to steal everybody.
So, actually, I'm not even gonna work on that because we're just gonna...
We're gonna be taking everybody home.
I love that.
I love that we can make our place so big and nice.
It's very strange not having all the stuff that I had from before.
Oh, wait, sorry.
Confidential document for...
Oh, specs for R&D.
That's right, the grenade and everything.
Our fatigues.
We can be naked.
You know.
Good for players who like raw, intense combat.
I feel like someone's gonna screenshot me looking at likes raw.
It's right next to my... Like raw.
I like
how you beat up people and they go, OMG, hi big boss.
Oh, yeah.
Well, unfortunately, in this game, you don't get to run around Mother Base.
But they actually implement that for V, so that's fun.
So, time to get a mission, baby.
Ready?
What?
You'd rather keep wandering from conflict to...
Select the mission that you wish to participate in.
Are you guys ready for some of the missions that you have to do over and over and over again?
Raw and intense in the love box.
Got it, boss.
Fulton recovery.
MSF soldiers only.
Snake has knocked out a radio soldier in the supply facility at Puerto del Alba.
We got it.
Also, this one...
Will you play Death Stranding 2?
I'd love to, yeah.
I gotta finish Death Stranding 1, though.
Mission prep.
We gotta...
Okay, we got our Fulton.
We got our Zzz's.
Can I... I don't wanna... Oh, that's right.
We can only...
Oh, it's not developed yet.
We can't even use Snake.
We gotta use someone else.
Snake already did the heavy work.
I think alligators are best, but...
Oh yeah, alligator.
For those wondering...
I did see a comment.
And it was only one comment in the pre-chat.
So if you're here, this is not just addressed to you, but to everybody.
Because some people might be wondering.
Obviously, I want to play missions with people.
Oh no.
No, no, no.
It's not a bad thing.
Just the comment was someone saying, I hope that she plays some of the missions.
Or she plays the missions by herself.
Because they saw another VTuber who played this before in the past.
And the last time that they did it, they played with people.
But I distinctly remember seeing another VTuber that did that.
That only did the boss fights with other people.
And did most of the solo missions themselves.
I'm just saying.
But, I mean, I've already played this game.
So I honestly would like to play with people as much as possible.
So I don't think it would be bad to do most of the missions.
With everybody.
In fact, I think that would be way more fun to do co-op.
And since I don't get so many chances to play with you guys.
I always want to find ways that I can include you guys in streams.
So for me, Peace Walker is extremely fun because of that.
Yeah, that's kind of my thought process on it.
Since the last time I did play it, I did the bosses with people.
And most of the missions by myself.
But I think for this, I would like to play more with people.
Yeah, that's how I feel about it.
So if you have an Xbox...
Honestly, I feel like I should have done like a...
I feel like I should have done like a poll.
Which do you have?
Xbox or PS3?
Or Playstation rather.
PC.
This game is not on PC.
Thank you so much for the 20 gifts!
Thank you!
Got mine ready boss.
So...
Waiting for you on my Xbox right now, Minto.
If it comes... I think I mentioned it earlier.
But I'll say it again just in case someone missed it.
If it comes down to where more people have the PS3 version or PSP...
I think PSP and PS3 can both play together, right?
Since it's a Playstation network.
If it comes down to more people having it on the Playstation side than the Xbox side...
I will just...
You know, we can play the Xbox today and maybe in the future I switch.
And if not...
You know, if we still have a lot of people playing.
I can't... I say a lot.
I don't expect to have like so many people because it is an older game.
But you can still buy it if you do want to play.
And it is a lot of fun.
Console wars are back.
Does online still even work on 360?
I'm almost positive it does.
It literally... Let's see.
I don't... Well, OK.
Let me do this mission real quick.
And then we'll... OK.
Alligator, it's your time to shine baby.
Let me do this mission.
We're gonna go get this guy and then we're gonna...
We can test it out.
Minto is underestimating herself again.
I'm not!
I'm just saying I don't know how many people still, you know, have what we are playing on.
Get up next to them so the icon appears and push the action button.
Where is he?
No you didn't.
Don't lie.
Liars are ugly.
Like a... See, he's even telling me to play the game with people.
He's telling me.
Oh my God.
Wait.
That guy is not coming here, is he?
Who are you?
He's walking into the wall.
Wait, what is he doing?
Oh yeah, that's right!
OK, OK, OK!
I'm working on it!
Oh my gosh!
I forgot that I can
get...
I forgot!
No you didn't.
Here he goes!
Where... Where is...
Is he out yet?
There he goes.
And you!
And where is the other guy that we knocked out?
Hello!
Oh here you are.
Coming home with me!
We're getting more people.
And you!
I know, that's the mission.
Me too!
I love stealing men!
It's so fun!
Alright, alright.
No animals here.
No animals.
Show me...Oh!
The following words can now be infused with heroic spirit.
Oh my gosh!
That's another thing you can do!
For those who don't know this game yet, there is so much you can do!
It's just too much fun!
It's too much fun!
This game is so much fun!
I love this game.
Everything about it.
We know who you are big boss.
OK We got...Oh no, that's who we just were.
Show us our men.
Show us our new pals.
We got chicken grunt!
I'm a mountain boy.
All this water and boats and stuff.
Give me a mission, quick!
We got oar fish.
We got aardvark.
LIZARD!
We got a lizard!
So what if you get knocked out?
A few good smacks and you'll wake right up.
LIZARD!
He's so bad.
Look at him.
He's got like no stats.
But chicken grunt is pretty good.
Steal some from the enemy if you have to.
Or call for resupply.
Or search around the area.
I was just napping on the floor like I normally do.
When I woke up I was here.
Are you my boss now?
It's like a chicken hatching from the egg.
Yes, imprint upon me.
LIZARD!
I can't believe we got a lizard!
Nice
I see some people mentioning leech.
I once had a soldier named leech.
That guy...
He was not the best to ever do it.
He actually sucked.
But I'll never forget him.
Lizard looks the same in each playthrough.
So this isn't randomly generated?
They actually crafted each and every one of them?
Maybe.
If that's the case it's huge.
That guy sucks your blood.
He was just a leech.
He had no skills, no nothing.
And then he died and it was so sad.
You can see all the cutscenes.
The menu is a little confusing at first.
So basically you're gonna have the main ops as it says.
And then there's extra ops which is what we just did.
But like...
Oh wait, how do I...
How do I see the tapes?
Hold on.
Give me a second.
I heard I got recruited!
Oh my god!
Lizard!
Oh it's in the mission briefings.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Lizard and Jot.
Is there one here?
Skip, skip.
Oh yeah, yeah.
See?
So you can ask people too.
Let's see what Pies has to say about this.
She's so cute.
One thing I... I don't know why I can get behind the cassette tapes in this game.
Because you don't really have codec in this game so much.
Like in the traditional sense that it was in the last Metal Gear games.
But I don't know why I can't get behind the cassette tapes in MGSV.
It's just so...
I don't know.
V had so many.
There's a lot.
I think maybe because in this game, obviously, there's technical limitations because PSP.
So I'm just like, oh, you know, they can't do a full cutscene all the time.
But I don't know, like, it's so strange.
Metal Gear sometimes becomes like an audiobook.
Because you have that whole segment at the end of MGS2 where it's AI Colonel and AI Rose talking with Raiden.
That whole segment is just talking.
There's not a single cutscene.
Like, it's just... it's... but it works.
I don't understand.
I don't... I don't... I don't understand how it works so well.
I get so invested in it without, you know, the visuals.
I don't get it.
I love audio dramas.
Yeah.
It's so strange, right?
It just works.
I know.
It's so strange.
I mean, there is cutscenes...
Like, spliced in, obviously, but...
Like, that whole... I just think of how that whole segment is just them talking.
And how it... how I'm like, oh, I like this, but in MGSV, I don't like that.
And I don't know why in my brain it's different.
I can't under...
It's basically the same thing.
Tapes in V feel purely made to fill empty space without gameplay and a chore sometimes.
Maybe.
Gameplay also interrupts the tapes?
That's one thing.
I can't... I can't play the game and also listen to the tapes at the same time.
I have to be... I have to have my full focus on one or the other.
Like, I have to... I can't be running around in the desert while also listening.
Because I'm... I'm like... I'm too scared of getting caught.
Should we test it?
Join Xbox Live Party.
Oh.
Maybe...
Host search.
Or do I search?
I don't... I want to host.
Hold on.
Let's try.
Is the one who gave us this mission, right?
I guess.
I'll put her on.
Snake.
Paz, where are you?
Ciudad Coln, a school.
The teacher told me to stay here until things quiet down.
Teacher?
Oh, him.
He's...
Yeah, that's probably good advice.
See, he has a radio in his room so we can talk anytime.
Yes.
Groovy.
Groovy channel.
He's so soft with her.
Never felt what it's like.
Never even been interested in it.
Oh, shut up, Snake.
Sorry.
Listen, Paz, I think your idea is...
He's in his trauma era, you guys.
I hope they turn out to be right.
Yeah, me too.
Peace is in your name.
Who better to help bring it back?
Thanks, Snake.
I will be here whenever you need me.
See you later.
She's too cute.
Snake, use your radio to call people.
But stay alert.
You're in the middle of a mission and can't afford to let your guard down.
Got it.
Need to know more about Costa Rica?
When is trauma era?
Good to know.
We'll follow their transport route.
This should take us straight to their main base.
Okay.
From what I've seen, it looks like nukes.
Agreed.
The key thing now is to confirm whether those spears really are what we think they are.
And if so, why they're here.
Follow the transport route.
Find the nukes.
That's what I'm thinking.
First we should make contact with the Sandinista Commandante.
They can tell us more about what's up ahead.
But it looks like their hideouts already come under attack.
Oh no!
We better hope they're still alive.
Snake, infiltrate that cabin and secure the Sandinista's Commandante.
Neutralize any guards by knocking them out, putting them to sleep or even using the Fulton recovery system.
Yeah, I'm stealing everybody.
You choose how to handle it, boss.
They're all coming home with us!
Okay, now it'll let us host it.
It's so funny, like...
Well, not funny.
It's actually so tragic.
How...
Big Boss comes to be.
He is...
Truly just...
Just so manipulated by everybody.
Compared to, like, Solid Snake.
It's just so sad.
Alright, I'm gonna try hosting it.
Global.
So yeah, you do need the Xbox Live.
Everybody.
It's just one person can make it in.
We'll see if it works.
As expected of an educator.
How...
As expected.
Oh, wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Sorry, I didn't do my mission prep.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I didn't think about it.
We gotta think of this too.
So these are, like, the things we could say.
Hold on.
I know I don't have so much unlocked yet, but...
There's important ones in here.
Like this one?
My own snake sound bank.
It's so dangerous.
Okay, that should be good.
Sorry, sorry.
We're all good now.
Okay, we're all good now.
Starting the mission.
So it does work!
Yahoo!
So exciting!
Oh, I forgot to equip the version 2.
It's okay.
It's okay, we'll equip it next time.
A country without an army.
I'm not playing this on a 360, by the way.
You don't have to have a 360.
If you have, like, a...
You can get it on any Xbox.
Hmm...
So...
Oh my gosh!
You're pretty good!
Wait, how do I...
We're syncing?
Why are you...
What is this?
What's going on here?
Why are we in sync?
How do I...
How do I do it again?
I don't remember.
Snake out!
Wait, Takedo!
How do I do it again?
Go to the menu.
And change your option.
Wait.
No.
Do you wanna get in?
Come on in!
Okay.
That's enough.
How do I...
I can't remember how to do the talking menu.
Oh my god!
Hey!
Stop following me!
This is weird!
I can't remember.
I'm trying to figure it out.
Oh, communication!
A...
Okay, let's go!
No!
No box time.
Takedo, you got in my shot.
What are you doing?
What are you doing right there?
Oh my god!
Takedo.
It's either that or take out every last enemy soldier.
You were supposed to help me.
You were supposed to help!
What just happened?
Huh?
Fulton recovery helicopter is complete.
Fulton recovery subject confirmed on board helicopter.
Cover.
No!
Not enough room, huh?
We'll keep it here at the base.
Alright.
Onwards?
Let's go.
Peace Walker is one of my favorite Metal Gear games.
I've been waiting for this stream.
Hope you have lots of fun.
Thanks Brandon!
Me too!
Okay, back to sneak.
Back to sneaking.
Where are you?
There you are.
I'm...
I can't see anything.
Stop you guys!
I'm...
I'm playing a game!
I wish I...
Can you blow this up?
That would be so cool.
I'll have to turn it off later, I think.
Okay.
Wait, are we lost?
Oh no, we're not lost.
I know where we are.
I got one guy.
Oh, good job, good job.
I did that one.
I'm saying good job to myself.
Oh shoot.
Where did he go?
Nope.
He's gonna see them!
Uh oh.
Nothing?
Oh, good job, good job, good job.
Good job Minto, thanks.
Thanks.
Yeah!
Oh, thanks.
They're coming home.
Yeah, grab all their things.
Take everything that they're worth.
Yeah, take everything that's...
Roll over.
Oh, nice.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
I'm taking them.
D'oh.
Is that everything?
Okay.
You ready?
Go, go, go.
I'll turn the notice off after this.
Just ignore them for now.
Go, go, go.
Corrupted.
The boathouse should be close by.
Neutralize the security detail and make contact with the Commandante.
Good job Mii.
Did you see that one?
Did you see that?
It's not over yet.
Oh, sorry.
You're right.
Pay attention.
You're right, you're right, you're right.
Oh!
How do you do?
Oh shoot.
What?
I'm helping you!
What are you talking about?
Give me a hand.
Oh shoot.
I got him.
We're fine.
Look at you hiding, you coward.
Wait, there's a guy up there.
Don't get too comfy.
There's a guy up there.
Well, he'll go to sleep in a second.
Yeah, you're seeing things, bozo.
Come home.
Oh, good job.
Oh, my bad.
Sorry, sorry.
Sorry.
You were doing that.
Okay, you guys.
You guys, it was silly at first, but please.
I'm not...
Please.
Yeah, there he goes.
I got his ass.
Okay.
Oh, I keep forgetting to take every... rob them of all their...
Wait, what's happening?
No!
I was supposed to get one more man!
Thanks, Chiquito!
I took them all out.
But I wanted to take him home.
I wanted to take him home.
Who is it?
El Che?
No way!
What do we do?
Everyone gets a line.
My old man!
El Che?
Amanda?
Ch...
Don't wag that in her face like that!
Snake!
Oh, my goodness!
Gosh!
Oh yeah, a photographer.
I love birds!
They're pretzels.
Wow, she's so good at bluffing.
The child craves the nicotine.
Papa Noel.
It's him!
Howdy, Chico.
This little waddle.
They have a base near here.
There's a factory to the north, across a suspension bridge.
Factory to the north, across a bridge.
Have you seen the big transport boat, mercenary crew, on the Rio del Jade?
You mean the barge?
It's upstream from here, up toward Yasu.
Any idea what's on it?
I could introduce you to some of our compas up there, but I don't recommend going to the mountains.
We've lost a lot of people there.
They take us captive.
Torture us for information about our compas.
And then they kill us like pigs.
This was our last hideout.
The final refuge for el enfrente.
After being pushed out of Nicaragua and into this vicious paradise of Costa Rica.
Then, el monstruo attacked.
A monster.
And my old man.
My old man.
Papa.
You are the hope.
Our hope.
Now that Papa is gone, my sister is the commander of the revolution.
Do not listen to him.
Papa was a hero, who fought by Sandino's side.
I am only his daughter.
You need a special talent to become cacique.
It takes someone great to unite all of las compas.
Sorry to interrupt, but leaders don't choose themselves, neither do heroes.
You carry on his legacy of la Esperanza and they'll follow you, no question.
You think so?
My compas trust me, but not one of them calls me comandante.
Amanda!
See what I mean?
El Colibri!
What should I make him?
No!
We
got this!
Is this Fortnite?
OK, I got this.
I got this guys.
One shot.
I think I got it.
I got this.
It didn't even give me a chance.
See, I didn't even do that.
Chico!
No, he won't survive the fall.
Out of my way!
Did you not hear what he said?
Better for him to die at the hand of a compa than suffer their torture.
What about our men then that we bolted?
Stay here.
As long as I'm still alive, I might as well retreat.
Over here!
Fine, Chico.
Ventaremos!
One day...Some annoying worker disappeared one day and then a week later you fall asleep on the job and you wake up and you've been kidnapped to work with that co-worker again.
Sorry about that alert earlier.
Xbox controls dip?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hatsune Miku!
Good thinking.
We can follow her.
Head for the next outpost and make contact with Amanda if she's still alive.
Roger.
One of my favorite things about the Metal Gear games is how disproportionately...
How the technology is so disproportionate across all the games.
It's like, Peace Walker is in the 70s, yet we have this flying unmanned machine.
I need a comic version of the Super Chat featuring Spongebob and Squidward.
What?
MGSV tech is insane.
I know!
It's so crazy!
Yeah, we got a sniper.
Oh, we got missiles.
Yippee!
Alligator.
Lungfish.
Good.
People are...People are gaining...
People are gaining...What's it called?
Let's see, who do we got?
Oh, wait.
Duker?
D-U-Y?
I hardly even know her.
How do you say his name?
Dweeker?
Moulin Rass...Didn't we get another one?
My great-grandpa used to tell me, Sunny, bananas are good for more than just eating.
What does that mean?
What is great-grandpa telling you?
It means diver in Dutch.
Cool.
Great-grandpa.
Mandrill.
I know it takes more than weapons to make us strong and all, but at least give us some decent gear, alright?
Okay, gosh.
You also have to create the gear.
Pause, is that you?
Leech!
I'll find my way back to you.
I may not be as good as many things, but...
Anyways, see you on MSM.
Leech!
Oh my gosh, seeing your ugly mug again is so great.
I like the little descriptions for each person.
Obviously, I'm not gonna read them every time for each person, but it's still so fun.
Grouper?
I hardly even know her.
Mosquito.
Costa Rica is full of swamps.
Perfect for a mosquito.
Make sure we got a good supply of dry socks.
The last thing we need are fungal infections.
Isn't that... Don't you get that from... Isn't...
Athlete's foot, right?
One time, Moon Race's grandpa sat on a banana and of course that changed his life.
I feel like I need to apologize for the follow.
It's not that I'm uncomfortable.
Don't worry about it, Casey.
Thank you for...
I appreciate the apology, of course, but don't feel like you...
It doesn't make me uncomfortable.
It was just the amount of notifications that kept popping up.
Don't worry about it at all.
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
I'm not even a little upset.
Jaguar!
Give me an order, boss.
I can't say it.
Jaguar.
It's a jaguar.
I can't say it.
Jaguar.
It's a jaguar.
I can never seem to balance work and pleasure because whatever I'm working on turns into pleasure.
MSF's got a real colorful crown now, don't we?
I've become so attached to these stupid men.
I just can't...
I love them the most ever.
Ready when you are, boss.
Ah, kudu.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, that's all of them.
They're just so great.
Auto-assign.
Yeah!
Rank 2!
Let's go to our R&D.
Who wrote these?
Kojima.
I have no idea, honestly.
I wouldn't be surprised if it's him.
It's all so silly.
Gun.
Handgun.
This one is lethal, no?
I've become so attached to these stupid men.
It's just the story of you and MGS, huh?
It's true!
It is true.
Pronouncing jaguar is easy.
It's caramel.
Do you guys say car-mel or car-mel?
I can't.
I don't like saying car-mel.
Car-mel.
Caramel.
I've always said caramel.
That's when you're a real freak.
Caramel.
Car-mel.
Where were we?
Fulton.
Throwing weapon.
What is it under?
Wait, I thought we could do the new... Can we not?
I thought we could...
I thought we had Fulton level 2.
Do we not have to research that?
Oh, it's under items.
I'm such a silly goose.
Sorry.
That's expensive.
5000.
I pronounce it car-mel most of the time but sometimes depending on the context I'll pronounce it car-mel.
Oh yeah.
That's fair.
And then other... we'll get more stuff later.
It's the wall.
More missions baby.
Go lethal at some point for variety?
I just don't feel like... I don't know.
I'm just so used to being non-lethal.
But also we got to collect as many men as possible, no?
Oh, do you guys mind?
Actually I got to go to the bathroom real quick.
Give me a second.
I got to go to the little ghost's room.
And I want to stretch too.
Okay.
Just a short, short break.
Short, short break.
Oh, what did I just do?
I just hit my...
There we go.
Okay.
Everybody, stretch.
Get drink.
I won't be so long.
I might get some tea though.
I might get a warm drink too.
I don't know yet.
Okay, I'll be happy.
I'll be happy.
Thank you for waiting.
I forgot... I also realized I forgot to turn off the notifications.
Oh, hi.
My cat is in there.
Welcome back.
No, don't scatter.
Where are you going?
Go back.
You can't leave.
I faulted you here.
You're mine now.
You're mine now, okay?
Say yes.
Yes, boss.
Let me let my cat out.
What are you doing, stinky girl?
You're so cute.
Oh, she just meowed.
Okay, hold on.
Let me let her out.
Alright.
Let me turn off the notifications.
Oh, sorry.
Give me a second.
Settings.
Where is it again?
Preferences.
Notifications.
Off.
Allow notifications.
Oh, okay.
We're back.
Off.
Oof.
Yay!
I'm glad Paws is around for her namesake's game.
I know!
Right?
So perfect.
Except I joke a lot.
This is a...
This is not a spoiler.
It's a thing that happens later on in the game.
But I think without context, it's fine.
But when she gets really...
She likes to fight Butaro a lot.
They are always fighting.
This morning I was trying to sleep.
And they were fighting on top of me.
Like, she likes to sleep a lot in between my legs.
And Butaro walks up to her and just starts fighting her for some reason.
And so it was all on top of me.
They were fighting.
Who starts the fight?
Either one of them.
They are always just playing around.
And she is kind of crazy.
She is still very much like a kitten.
And so she is always running around and destroying things.
And so I'm always just like...
Paws says peace day never came.
So, we are going to pursue Amanda.
Track and locate Amanda the Sandinista leader and obtain intel on the enemy's bases and the route to use to transport the nuclear material.
And I will once again post.
Because why not?
It's more fun.
Create.
Okay, let's see.
Fast!
Harris...
Harry the AI?
Is that what it says?
Thank you!
Welcome!
Cool, cool, cool.
Alright, mission prep.
And I do want to say too, you don't have to be good at this game or anything to play.
It's all good.
It's all good, baby.
I know exactly what has been equipped.
Let's hear what Pies says real quick.
Oh yeah, there's so many things.
Oh gosh.
We'll listen to them later.
Here, let's see what he says.
To get to your next objective, you'll need to backtrack along the way you came for a bit.
Don't get too comfortable just because you know the terrain.
The enemy knows you're out there now.
They'll be out in greater force than before.
Proceed with caution.
Refrain from using firearms unless absolutely necessary.
Looks like I'll have to cross the river.
Yeah, there's a suspension bridge you can use.
It's the only way across.
You'll have to be a little creative to keep from being spotted.
So, I cross the bridge, go through the swamp, and come to a banana plantation.
Complete with it's own factory by the looks of it.
It's going to feel a lot different moving through that area compared to the forest.
Stay on your toes.
Also, you may encounter Sandinista prisoners along the way.
Try and save as many as you can with Fulton Recovery.
I'll keep an eye out.
Alright, sorry to keep you waiting, Harry.
Harry.
Alright, let's start.
Keep that one guy away.
That's what I was thinking.
What was his name?
I can't remember.
With his great grandpa, he learned...
He's a descendant of the banana man.
Starting.
Oh gosh, the server is chugging along.
It's cause you're a brat, Ash.
I have to go.
Thanks Brandon.
Thanks for coming by.
Listen up.
For us, there is no victory.
The models in this game look so good.
Everybody is so good in this game.
Oh no!
Why are we sinking?
What does that mean?
What does snake formation mean?
Oh my god, you're scaring me.
Are you gonna do anything?
Maybe I can get this guy.
Good job!
Wait.
No, no!
I got him.
Wait, I want to Fulton these guys.
I'm taking them home with me.
Oh shoot, I forgot to...
Yeah, take them home.
Take them home.
Through the roof!
This is so evil.
Do you have to crouch like that?
Do you have to...
Do you have to crouch...
It's too horrible.
Ok, let's keep going.
Wait.
We came from this way.
No!
Impressive!
Wait.
Wrong thing.
There we go.
Wait.
Wait, hold on!
Is there anything in here?
Don't leave!
Ok, there's nothing in there.
False alarm.
I'm coming.
I thought he yelled banana.
No!
Look at us, running...
Wait, yeah, wait.
No...
Oh, good job.
Why didn't I get him?
What the hell?
What?
What a waste.
Uh oh, we're stuck in a loop.
Uh oh.
No!
I got him.
You're ok.
You're safe with me.
Stick with Minto.
You're safe.
Hey, tell me I did a good job, you know?
I just saved your ass.
Is it this way?
I can't remember.
Where are we going?
This is where we came from before.
No, not this way.
Other way.
Why is he naked?
He's going to the beach!
I'm ready.
Spread out.
Where's the girl?
Oh yeah, we got her.
Oops.
My bad.
I got him.
Don't worry.
Amanda.
Is it this way?
Wait, hold on.
Can we high five?
Come here.
Come here!
No.
Nevermind.
Ah, shoot.
I think I had it first.
There we go.
Wait!
High five.
What is this?
This is so intimate.
Oh, we're sinking.
I don't know.
He's mine!
No!
I like the spulton that drops all their items.
It's kind of nice.
It's pretty nice.
I'm not going to lie.
Whee!
Spin to win.
Hehe.
Spooked ya, huh?
Yeah!
Is the wormhole spulton in this?
No!
This one, actually, you can just do however you need to.
Like, you can spulton them indoors.
Oops.
My bad.
Hold on.
I got him.
Don't waste.
I'm taking him home.
Notes.
I can't see anything.
Oh my god, game, please.
Game.
Take him home.
Country roads...
To the plains...
Where?
Harry!
Apologize.
That's your second offense.
Yeah, Dogeza.
Down on the ground.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Kaiser Hero.
Metal tank.
Two people.
Drop it, Kevin.
This is why I love playing with you guys.
It's so fun.
Why is he naked?
Why wouldn't you be?
It's just a fun day at the beach, no?
Oops.
He's asleep.
Oh, there's so many guys here.
Good luck with that.
I remember this place.
Oh my gosh, I remember this place.
Crazy.
I remember this place.
Can I get him through the fence?
I'm taking him down one by one.
Oh my god, gamer.
Holy shit.
Nice aim, boss.
Thank you.
Oops.
I said...
You don't see me.
We're all good.
It's clear.
Steal them all.
Take them home.
Wait, how many Fultons do I have left?
Four.
Someone might have to die.
Is there somebody in here?
The butterfly.
Butterfly.
I should take this guy.
Is he good?
I'm trusting you.
I only have one Fulton left.
But there's two guys.
No!
I'm not stealing too many men.
This is how you play the game, baby.
In V, when you Fulton people, they do start to hear it.
This game is very chill with it.
You can just Fulton anybody and it's all good.
What do I do with him?
Kill him with the banana.
Supper party.
Stay back, Harry.
OK, let's go.
I was gonna say, I hope there...Oh good, we got another fatigue.
I was gonna say, I sure hope there's no more...
I sure hope there's no more...prisoners.
For us, there is no victory.
Oh my god, I can't.
Any mission with the tanks are just like so...
You know?
They are just so...
Looks like
there's no way around it.
You up for this, Snake?
Laugh time, jerk.
In the next episode of Dragon Ball Z.
They are so 4 player co-op time.
Oh yeah, baby!
A kill.
Wait, we only had one alert phase.
415!
The mech battles are gonna get so murdered.
It's fine.
On a C for cool.
He has a dream.
What does that mean?
The Japanese!
Speaking of food, I'm getting a little hungry.
I'm gonna snack on some Goldfish.
Kaiz is what?
Half Japanese?
He's very proud of that half.
He's extremely proud of it.
Kaiz or Paz?
Kaiz, Kaiz, Kaiz with a K.
Oh no!
Well, we got plenty of new men, so...
Do I need the mess hall team tutorial?
I guess I'll look at it.
Supply sufficient provisions according to the size of your mother base staff.
Your current food supply is represented by food.
Morale will rise enabling soldiers to perform beyond their natural abilities.
Who would have thought they need to eat?
Boss, we're starving.
You can set quick comms message to back select buttons by hitting pause during a mission and going to the gear tab.
Thank you!
If morale falls too low, soldiers will defect and ultimately leave mother base.
Adequate staff to the mess hall team.
Thank you!
Alright, we got our first POW!
And you are chameleon.
Let's use our heads on this one.
Oh, actually his R&D is great.
Cockatoo!
Hey Miller, imagine snake having a kid.
What race should be the mother?
Blood from the east flows through your veins.
We got moth.
Flying weapons are usually pretty noisy.
They ought to be easy to find if you got a surround indicator.
Right boss?
GoldenEye.
GoldenEye is straight to the point.
I like you.
Marine Iguana.
I may not look it, but I'm turning 48 this year.
Drop the skin routine.
Let's drop the skin care.
Numfish?
Cardinal?
Starfish?
Boss, the R&D team is screwing around.
They are playing with cardboard boxes.
What the hell is that?
Crab.
Moonrassy.
Ostrichman.
Wait.
Raccoon.
Sometimes I get to thinking.
What is human life in the face of truly great scientific research?
Alpaca.
Wolf.
Just between you and me, I'm the guy who keeps MSF together.
You just got here!
Okay Wolf.
Jeez.
Honeybee!
Oh my gosh!
Honeybee.
Sniper rifles are best for precision long range shots.
Chameleon.
Okay, I think that's everybody.
Nice!
Auto-assign.
Okay.
Wow!
Our food is crazy.
I have a question.
Does auto-assign also...
work for the people that are already assigned?
You know?
Wolf is me and every job or project is started.
Or does it only auto-assign people in the waiting room?
Only for new recruits.
Bionic Hippo!
Thank you so much for the 10k!
Thank you!
It would just be so many people I'd have to move back and resort, you know?
Anyway, thank you!
Kaz's head is the Ken doll, yet he's half Japanese.
The Japanese half must be his lower half?
Go to all and auto-assign.
Oh, there is no auto-assign.
Sad.
So sad!
Japanese feet.
You would like that, wouldn't you?
Is there anything that we should be making?
There we go.
What's the M10?
Oh.
It's a machine gun.
Our good-o kit for now.
The analyzer.
I guess I'll grab this now.
OK.
Back to mission.
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee!
OK.
Everybody ready to join for...
Let's see.
I'm gonna need the big boys.
What's that?
Briefing first.
We can brief.
Help me Miller.
Nah, they're babies.
They're sinking.
Yeah.
We'll see how you feel when you actually have to face them in battle.
Snake, whatever you do, don't let them surround you.
The last thing you need is to get pushed into the vehicle's kill zone.
And pay attention to what your enemies say to each other.
You can improve your chances by figuring out what they're planning and using it to preempt their movements.
You don't always have to go toe-to-toe to win a fight.
Think like a gorilla.
Got it.
I'm thinking...
Hello!
Flying Taco!
Dull Bracelet!
And...Burg Boy!
What are these names?
Okay.
We don't need this guy.
We need the big boys.
We need the law.
And the grenades.
Tuxedo!
Tuxedo.
I'm excited.
Let's rock.
Do I need to change my fatigues?
You know what...
Water.
Naked Pink!
Let's rock.
Oh, I have to re-equip all my stuff.
Oh my gosh, I forgot that this is how that game works.
Oh my goodness, you...
Grenade.
And even I'll bring the smoke grenade too.
Anything else?
Empty mag.
We don't need to distract them right now.
Then a
love box always.
Camera so I can take pictures of everybody.
Alright, let's go!
Sorry to keep you waiting.
Let's go team!
Ripped Snake.
Are we all naked?
That would be so funny.
It would be so crazy.
Gorilla time!
I'm thinking like a gorilla.
That's why I took off my clothes.
The models in this game are so awesome.
I can't get over them.
And then I see them everyday because I own the... What's it called?
The Mountain Ducans.
I own the Mountain Ducans so I see everybody's pretty faces, all these pretty models everyday.
Silly gang.
Yeah, why are we all naked?
What happened?
Team, what happened?
Say cheese!
How do I use this?
Press RT.
Snake, come here!
Come here!
Everybody get in frame.
Say cheese!
Good, good, good.
Thank you!
What are we doing now?
I got the law.
Are we taking him down?
Are we just gonna go and blast him?
What should we do?
Why did you do that?
I think he's going and blasting.
How did he not get caught?
Oh my god!
Oh man!
I always forget to reload this thing.
Wow!
Oh yeah, start taking the guys home.
Oh, I don't think this guy is alive anymore.
Where could we be?
I
think I need it pretty bad.
Help who?
Oh
I'm out of ammo!
Take who down?
The Kapitan!
I'm taking him!
I shot him, but you know...
He's still alive.
He's so good at eating those bullets.
That was all you Minto.
Yeah, they were sleep bullets.
Rubber bullets, so true.
So true.
Yeah, let's go!
Let's go!
Good job team, good job team.
So serious.
Someone didn't get the memo.
On Saturdays we wear pink.
Nice.
Good job everybody, good job.
That was so good.
Chico?
Intruder detected.
Oh no!
This is what happens.
This is what I do too.
I'm fultoning.
Nice.
House.
How does it move so fast though with her, you know?
It shouldn't be moving that quickly.
OK.
Chico Libri.
You got this!
It's not letting me do anything yet.
No!
She's gonna say what is though.
I didn't go for that.
Shoot her.
Are you OK?
Amanda, are you good?
No, Chico.
She gotta have her smokes.
He gets it.
OK.
Sorry, I'm snacking.
That's what I can do with all my cocaine.
Banana factory.
Her bones!
Feet!
Yes, ma'am!
The bones, the bones.
Yes,
ma 'am.
Even the banana factory won't take the coke.
For anybody who doesn't know what I'm talking about, just watch the Keep Driving stream.
You're going after that cargo?
People probably like, what is Miss doing with cocaine?
Ahem.
Chico!
Don't spawn me in with nothing.
Oh, what the heck?
You're great!
Thanks, Nailo!
Thanks for joining us.
OK.
If he gives in, if he's about to sell out his compas, please, at least let him keep his honor.
No.
That's a promise I can't make.
Why?
Amanda, we gave up our homes, but we're still alive.
We're still fighting.
And there's always another reason to keep on living.
This theme is too good.
I feel alive again.
Amanda, join my unit until you've healed up.
Your unit?
Yeah.
Who are you?
Why are you here?
I'm a photographer.
That was unnecessary.
My reaction too.
You're a snake?
Oh boy.
Good night, little princess.
Let's fold in your way.
Kaz is like, a woman?
She?
You think that's where they're taking the nukes?
I'm sure of it.
Let's move.
I gave her the sleeping cigs.
Oh yeah, the one that you smoke it and the smoke blows in their face.
3 kills.
We got 5 guys.
Those are all you guys, so thank you.
Oh we got the tank!
Yippee!
Tortilla chips!
Burgers and fries.
Soft drink!
Banana.
Snake.
Amanda, how do you feel?
Some first helicopter ride.
I'll be perfectly happy if it's my last.
She would look better with a bandana on her head.
If you have any questions about American bases or mercenary units or about El Frente, just ask.
And please, do not forget my compas and Chico.
Don't worry.
It's good to be working with you, boss.
Snake, we can monitor her condition in sickbay.
Remember to assign roles to any POWs you bring back to Mother Base.
How this outfit gets built depends on who we assign to what jobs.
That will determine how Mother Base grows.
It's one of your most important roles, boss.
I'm doing it!
Yeah, I know.
Oh gosh!
I know!
Boss, one more thing.
Now what?
It's about sickbay.
Naturally we can use it for the sick or injured like we did with Amanda.
But we can't expect people to get better without the proper treatment.
So I figure we'll need a medical team for that.
The number of team members and their abilities will determine how quickly the sick and injured heal.
They can also monitor everybody's health.
Why is everybody not just healthy all the time?
Sink.
I am big boss.
Amanda.
She's so pretty.
Look at our little Mother Base.
It'll get much bigger though.
It'll become way bigger.
PTSD!
Tortilla chips.
Bayleed Whale!
You are now the matria libre of...what does that mean?
Mongoose!
Everybody get along now, okay?
You're next.
Why did you specify bandana on her head?
Maybe I'm just overthinking things but you got quite more freaky than normal today.
What?
It's because she's already wearing a bandana on her neck.
And I think she would look good with a bandana on her head like Snake has.
What?
I'm the freaky one?
You're the freaky one!
Get your head out of the gutter!
I'm talking as like...as an accessory!
You're talking weird!
What?
Freaky where?
Bro is the freaky one?
Yeah!
You just called yourself out.
You...you just self-reported.
Classic projections.
My first MGS game and I got to play with my OG.
Let's go!
Thank you.
Sus.
That was a classic where I...
I'm not seeing your response, ducky.
You're a little embarrassed about that?
How would it even be freaky?
How?
I regret nothing.
Let's see.
We've got Manta Ray.
No need for you to go, boss.
I've got this one covered.
I don't think you do.
We got Beetle.
You ever hear...you ever hear of these battle cries that make amazing things happen sometimes when you say them?
Crazy, huh?
What the hell?
Let's have some fun out there!
Says Hamster.
Okay, let's go to All.
Because we're going to need some people in the sickbay.
Or the medical team, I mean.
To take care of those in the sickbay.
So, Master Miller belongs in the food, to be honest.
But we'll keep him where he's at for now.
Where do I have NR&D?
Until we get, like, a stinky guy to go into NR&D, we'll keep Miller in there for now.
Let's see.
Lungfish.
I transfer you to medical team.
Oh, sorry.
I just realized my head is blocking it.
Just trust.
Okay, he was the only one that was good.
Everybody else is E.
We'll send some of the guys, like Orefish, he's all E's.
So we'll send him to medical team too.
We have faith.
You can sort by...you can?
List mode?
No.
How to sort?
How...
Start?
Ah, thank you.
Okay, okay.
Thank you!
Alright, so I put Lungfish in there.
No, why would he be in medical?
Oh, I guess that's his second best thing.
But they belong in NR&D.
It's probably okay for now.
Show them who's boss.
It's probably fine for now.
Did we have anything that we could...
Besides that?
Items?
Tortilla chips.
And we got a tank.
Let's go.
What?
Alright.
Oh no!
Who's driving this thing?
Drift!
It's a bumpy ride.
Choose your gear carefully.
Okay!
Back to mission.
Rescue Chico!
Is this actually the one where I rescue Chico?
Or is it the next mission?
I'm asking about the one where we have to search each...
each place.
Like the different buildings.
So we need you to infiltrate one of their bases.
A prison facility.
That's an app.
Not a tank.
My bad.
Nerd.
This is the one with the searching doors.
Okay, I want to do this one.
I want to do this one myself then.
Yeah.
Amanda.
Lucia.
Okay.
Peepholes!
What pervs!
Thank you!
Hello!
I'm going to do this one single because I like going through the different houses.
So I hope you guys don't mind.
I think we're good.
We'll go back to...
We're in concrete?
Maybe we should do like a different fatigue.
Some different camo.
Nah.
Survival.
Maybe we're fine.
Do the Tiger Stripe.
Is it better?
Survival.
You.
I don't really have much of anything else.
This is fine.
Okay.
Fulton.
Russian.
Oh.
Eco.
Tiger Stripe is good for your great indoors.
This is a membership chat.
Thank you!
Thank you very much!
Okay.
I see.
Oh, I'm sorry chat kind of blocks the... what's it called?
The radar.
It's just...
It's lighting up a little bit over this yonder.
Over yonder.
Oh, I see him.
I got him.
Oh, did I?
I think I...
Didn't... No.
I don't think it was done.
The... What's it called?
The...
I don't think I should waste my Fultons.
What if he sucks?
The analyzer.
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe we're fine leaving him.
I don't want to waste it.
How many do I have?
Ten!
Maybe it's okay.
Oops.
I do want your stuff also.
I'm taking it home.
What if he's good?
You're right.
You're alright.
We'll take them all home.
These are our men.
And I love them equally.
Every single one of them is coming home with me.
Think of it as gotcha.
One of them... What if the one I left behind... What if he was leech?
What basin?
What are you talking about?
Junction.
Okay.
We're gonna go to the left.
Master collection volume 2 win.
I know!
Right?
I got a little...
A little distraction.
A little thing to kind of...
Throw you off your way.
I don't think I can get that guy.
I do remember kind of there being...
Who said that?
Oh my god.
This guy.
You son of a bitch.
Leave me alone!
Are you not shooting at me?
Why are you so confused?
Damn it.
That was so close.
I saw it like zoom past the front of his face.
Got him.
Nothing here.
I think that's the only sniper?
I was gonna say...
I was literally the sentence saying...
I think I remember a sniper being over there.
And then he totally got me.
Take him home.
Sniper.
Was there one over here?
No.
Take you home too.
You're gonna extract him?
Oh!
I forgot.
Next game we'll have to deal with Kazuhira's judginess over who I...
Who I deem worthy of joining our cause.
Come here.
Come here little prisoner.
I wish I could get him down.
I don't ever remember how to do it.
I wish I could grab him though.
Aren't the snipers pretty good?
You're right there!
Please!
Oh well.
Too bad.
So sad.
Fulton Mine or Rocket Launcher?
Dang.
The snipers have the best stats.
Just tease players.
They're just little teases.
I'll find him.
I think I can get him.
Take him home.
So the blue doors.
But I like this part because you can hear all the funny...
What's... Oh my gosh.
Spook the heck out of me.
Blind.
Absolutely blind.
All of them.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
That's a blue door?
I'm too good at the game.
I'm sorry.
No!
I was literally just saying!
I wanted to hear the other...
The birds of the valley.
I'm too good.
I'm just too good.
I didn't even get to collect that guy.
I took down...
It's just a broken leg.
This is where Big Boss becomes a little crazy.
Look at Chico's face.
He's got no thoughts behind that eye.
Yeah.
Disappears.
What?
Close enough.
I'm just making fun of my weight.
Hmm?
Okay.
Something that could keep the world in balance.
Or destroy it.
His face!
Hole?
Look, I get it.
Even revolutionaries need to pay the bills.
Still, it must be tough for a kid like you to swallow.
You're damn right it is!
The road they use to transport stuff is the same one mi viejo used to smuggle drugs.
They sold the drugs to the norteamericanos and used the profits to fund the army.
They tried to keep it hidden from me.
Is that why you went camping?
Yes.
I managed to sneak into the plant a few times and...
I tried to set it on fire.
Oh my god, arson arc.
This is a Disney movie moment.
I'm not a kid anymore!
I'm 13 years old!
Mi viejo!
Dad!
I can't go back.
I can't face everybody.
You told them where your compas are.
Time to die!
Nothing to be ashamed of.
Pain gets the better of us all.
No!
He's trying to reassure him.
Snake!
Chico's not a man!
So good.
Huh?
Fight with me, little soldier.
Show me how strong you really are.
Yeah, our first child, soldier!
Let's go!
Dry your tears.
Then promise me one thing.
No smoking until you get older.
Remember, real heroes are never as polished as the legends that surround them.
You got it, boss.
Snake is fine.
What's that?
Get faulted!
Rescue Chico mission complete!
Maybe we'll go back and do that one and like...
We can listen to the other doors and stuff.
Hmm...
C4?
Support strike.
Oh nice!
It's a short mission, yeah.
Chico!
What?
That's such a...that's such a dramatic...
What's special about the other doors?
The other...the other prisoners just say funny things.
I mean but he...
But he is...
He's only twelve!
I think though...
It's kind of like the situation he's in, right?
You don't want to treat him so much like a kid.
Yeah, I'll talk once with him.
Shoot.
Oh, they haven't survived.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
The UMAs.
Yeah, the UMAs.
Is that right?
Okay, sure.
Welcome to the reason why there's Monster Hunter Controls.
Yeah, I was saying earlier though.
I don't want to talk over them.
But it's like if you...Goddammit Miller!
Ads.
Yeah, Snake is so sassy.
Okay.
But when it's like...
You don't want to treat him like a kid where he knows nothing.
Because that could be so dangerous for him, you know what I mean?
Yeah, he's a kid, but at the same time you have to be like...
You have to make sure that he doesn't do something stupid because he's just ill-informed.
Snake loves child soldiers, so...
Tortilla chips!
A new plant has been built.
Let's go.
We're expanding.
Holy moly.
Every snake does?
A solid snake like child soldier?
Yeah, Sunny.
She's not really a soldier.
Alright.
No, we're good.
I think we got it.
We got well!
Wow.
Chico.
Ancient dinosaurs and rare monsters.
I actually kind of like the way you fight.
Oh, this is the guy that was...
That was in the brig.
What?
What is the square box stat?
What square box?
Oh, the one that currently says E?
That is...
Is that the recon?
I could go for a nice cold soda.
Oh wait, I forgot to read the names.
Mongoose, another genet...
Intel?
OK, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Horse!
I got two yolks in my egg this morning.
So I'm going to work twice as hard today.
Or at least complain half as much.
Anaconda.
I got a daughter.
She's going to be 12 next year.
I have to make it out of this alive.
Surf Perch.
Wish I could see the Loch Ness Monster or Quetzalcoatl once in my life.
He wants to see the pretzel.
Minky!
No way!
We got Monkey!
Before I became a mercenary, I was a doctor.
Would you like to try this new drug I'm working on?
Why do you have zero medic stat?
If you are a medic.
Monkey, I think you need to find a new profession.
Nice.
We got Chico under Intel.
Let's go.
Amanda is still sick.
When can I move her out?
I guess it will let me know.
It will let me know.
Let's see.
What was the start?
Chico Miller.
Amanda.
Anaconda is already in there.
Chameleon shouldn't go in there.
Whatever.
I wasn't a good doctor.
That's why he changed jobs.
Check your in-game gift delivery when you get...
Wait, where is that again?
Also, we can see Mother Base, you guys.
Isn't it so beautiful?
This is us.
This is our home.
This is Mother Base.
It's small now, but it will be the biggest ever.
It's getting bigger, I know.
I love brunette Mito.
I'm not brunette!
My hair is black right now.
But thank you.
Database.
It's not this, no?
Log.
No.
Oh wait, I think it's here.
Delivery!
No, we're okay.
Inbox!
It's okay.
I didn't want any gifts anyway.
I
didn't...
Happy White Day.
Yes, I didn't stream on White Day.
I did it again.
I think actually some people said off-stream donuts.
For White Day, thank you.
But I didn't get so much for White Day.
Even though I gave you something for Valentine's Day.
It's just how it is, I guess.
Tickle!
I'm not a kid.
I'm 12.
So funny.
Oh yeah, we have lots of extra ops we can do too.
Target practice no limit.
Look at all these ones that we have.
Maybe we should do the classified documents.
What does it give us?
One minute for penalty for triggering an alert.
I'll probably save some of the extra ops for another day.
I'm almost a little bit on a time limit because I'm meeting with some friends tonight.
Let's do...
Pursue the Jungle Train.
I want to do the first box though.
I think we'll be able to get to there at least.
Post!
Alright, get in here!
Get in here!
Micmac!
OK!
Are you already Micmac?
I think I'm ready.
What is the location like?
It sounds so horrible.
Why can't I talk to...
Why can't I talk to Miller?
What is that?
Stout.
Good thing I'll be slithering around.
Bigfoot!
I get it.
So true.
I'm cool.
I'm cool, I'm cool.
You know a lot about this place.
What are you saying?
I've been there before, when the KGB ran it, yes.
But it is not as if I enjoyed it.
No, I just meant you know a lot about how the enemy works.
I hope so.
Anyway, did you talk to Chico about the terminal?
He said it's where they transfer the cargo onto trucks.
Meaning the facility is of considerable importance to them.
Don't get careless.
I won't.
By the way, I've heard of a shortcut that cuts straight to the coffee factory to the east of the village.
But I've never used it myself.
Check it out if you're interested.
Thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Please, you're welcome.
Please!
OK, we're ready!
Let's go Big Mac!
Let's go!
Love coffee factories.
Make the whole area smell great.
Do you peruse coffee factories often?
Try again.
Please try not to spam the same message over and over again.
I would like to play them in the future though, yes.
Sorry.
No worries.
Just letting you know.
The train terminal is on the other side of the coffee factory.
Big Mac!
Be careful!
She's right there!
To get to the coffee factory, you'll first need to backtrack to the fork in the road.
Did that just auto on him?
Don't move.
Slight aim correction.
Yeah, that was strange.
Where are you?
Oh, hi.
Wait, is this the guy I did before?
Let's take him home.
Or is this the guy you just did?
Oh no, there is this guy over here.
Wait a second.
A hand?
Hold on!
I want to take this guy.
I need all the men I can get.
Where are you?
I don't even know where you are.
Oh, hi.
I'm following.
No!
What the hell?
Why did you leave me?
Someone's
coming.
Did you just kill that guy?
No, he's asleep.
Just a win.
I'm coming.
Oops, sorry.
I took the bot.
Hold on.
How do I set it down?
Wait, hold on.
Oh, A to drop.
Or A.
There you go.
Must be the win.
I didn't know that there was a shortcut.
That's craziness.
Where are we?
Where are we going?
Oh there we are.
Okay.
You're running.
This way?
Oh yeah, there we go.
What a show off.
This guy is such a show off.
Oh, I have the fancy suit that makes no noise when I run.
Yeah, yeah.
Gonna grab this guy.
No, thank you.
I'm grabbing supplies.
Hold on, I'm just looting a little bit.
I don't think there is anything else.
Okay.
Oh my god.
What is that?
Hold on, let me get him.
Just kidding.
What is that sound?
Are we sinking?
I got his ass.
Snake out.
I don't actually know what sinking... I think it means that they can just like follow you without doing anything.
It's kind of confusing.
Where?
Oh.
Oh you got him?
Good job.
I didn't see him up there.
We're going.
We're continuing onwards.
Forwards.
Is that another... What is that?
Prisoner?
No.
No you don't.
I'm also...
Oh shoot.
He just got... He just saw his friend.
Prisoner.
No you don't.
Anyway.
I got him!
Thank you.
I hope I don't run out of Fultons.
I could do a supply thing though.
Increases your stamina and other stuff apparently.
Oh fun.
Thanks!
Look at Snake shuffling him.
I see another... I see another prisoner in there too.
Did you get him?
Good job.
You're pretty good.
I got this guy.
I got him.
Oh there's two more prisoners!
Oh golly.
What?
What do you mean you're going all in?
What do you mean by that?
Where did he go?
Mick Mick!
Don't sleep on him like that.
I'm the faster climber.
I hear the footsteps of a man.
Oh my god he's right there.
Holy cow.
We can take him down.
CQC him!
Knock him out!
What is he saying?
What do you got?
He's got a big chip.
What else do you got?
Where were you hiding those?
Yeah, cower.
Sit and cower.
One moment please.
Let's acquire more ration.
Those are imperative for me.
Yeah!
Snake out!
Snake in!
We straight up took the guy's lunch.
Where was he hiding those?
Oh my gosh, do you think that when he came into work today...
His pals were just like, whoa.
Whoa, soldier.
You're not on any kind of sneaking mission with that dumpy.
He's just like, it's just a chip.
What are you packing?
Is that a bag of chips or are you just happy to see me?
Wait, isn't this another tank mission?
He's like, I'm keeping these.
No one's taking them.
Little did he know.
Mr. Money, look at the membership bag.
Nevermind.
Oh, it's right now.
OK.
How do we want to do this?
Oh.
How do I reload?
There we go.
I remember.
Stinky!
Oops.
Sorry, that was my fault.
I got him though.
That was my fault.
I'll take them down once you do it, you know.
Oh my gosh.
Warn me when you're about to grenade.
Please.
In fact, I can't even see anything to shoot.
Can you see?
What's going on in there?
Are you OK?
I can't take home any of them.
I have no more...
Wait.
I didn't even get the supply thing.
I didn't even include it.
That's it anyway.
I love turning Snake into a passenger princess.
I shot them.
I shot one guy.
We're all good.
It's fine.
I'm doing my part.
It's empty.
64779647796477964779
I don't think you should shoot that next to the nukes.
I think that's a poor decision.
Oh my god.
6477964779
There's our tank mission.
I thought that there was one here.
Wow!
In the next episode of Dragon Ball Z.
Yay!
Thank you!
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for showing off.
See, I would be that good too if I had a nice sneaking suit and all the fancy accessories.
You know what I'm just saying.
I would've also... I would've also been so great.
Of course.
Yeah, of course.
Sonic Eye.
Running around at the speed of sound.
OK.
6...5...779.
I don't remember the rest.
Sonic Eye.
Rhinoceros.
Jaguar.
Oh, Frillshark.
What are you doing, buddy?
Bat!
Have you ever tried chorizo?
It's a Mexican sausage.
Good stuff, especially when you fry it.
I'm so hungry.
Don't talk about food.
Mute.
Yuck.
You're one smart customer.
Meerkat.
Beetle.
Cabbage White.
Starfish.
I could learn to like this outfit.
Chorizo.
Llama.
Yellowtail.
Bat.
Oh, OK.
That's everybody.
And...go to your posts!
The magazine!
Let's do some R&D stuff since I don't think I've touched it in a minute.
Oops.
Oopsie.
What is this?
Oh, this is the magazine.
Sorry.
C4?
We'll do that, yeah.
M60.
Why not?
Didn't I do the analyzer?
Oh, this is analyzer 2.
Sonic Eye.
Displays nearby sound sources and animated symbols.
And surround indicator.
Yeah, the analyzer.
Oh, wait.
I don't think I...
Wait.
Sorry.
Is this one...search range and speed.
I'm trying to decide which one I want.
I'll do this.
OK.
Alright.
Who wants to fight a tank?
Ouch.
Sorry.
I fell on my knee in Japan and it's really bruised.
And I just slapped my knee.
Get down.
That's the enemy,
isn't it?
Host.
Create.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
I almost read my own name.
Mobius.
Dull bracelet.
Welcome back.
Noble Random.
Thank you.
Mission prep.
I don't know how many people are trying to get in.
But...wait a few...
What's the words?
Wait a few...
If you don't mind, a few games before you join another mission.
Just to try and let as many people in as possible.
Sorry, I meant to say that earlier.
I fell on my knee in Japan.
Kaz approved.
Mito Kaz Phantom.
Yeah.
Why do you think I like him so much?
We're both weeaboos.
Tortilla chips.
Wait, we have a lot of those actually.
Crazy.
Sure.
I really don't need all this stuff, honestly.
You know what?
It's fine.
Guys, I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry!
Rejoin.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you Mito.
What did I do?
Thank you for the super chat.
Survival.
Is there anything else we can equip here?
Grenade.
Smoke grenade.
Supply.
Will this...
Receive ammo and items.
So maybe this will give me more Fultons.
Wait.
Come back in.
Or someone come in.
Come in.
Do you read me?
I've got supply too.
Let's go!
And...
Join.
That wasn't a join.
Join!
Join.
OK.
Welcome back, Micmac.
Let's go!
Last guy disappeared.
You can rejoin next time.
Don't apologize, D.Va.
Survival.
Yeah, get all suit up.
Take your time.
You're all good.
Someone else said it's not fair for me to join again.
No, it's OK.
I'm sorry.
Micmac was in earlier too.
Maybe there's not so many people.
Chico!
Chico, Chico, Chico.
I only joined because it looked like she needed an extra.
I just want to play with as many people as possible because it's fun that way.
Oh I forgot to put on my panties.
The pink panties.
Ah man.
That's our tank outfit everybody.
That's the tank uniform.
Thank you so much for the Akazopa!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
Yeah team, yeah team, yeah team, yeah team.
Wait, wait, wait!
Oh I forgot my...I forgot my camera.
Uh...
Guys...
I think we messed up.
Guys, I think we messed up.
Why do you have two in a row?
Oh my God!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh.
Okay back to the law, back to the law.
My rations.
I'm attacking.
I'm getting my...
Hey you guys don't die over there, okay?
What are you doing?
Oh I'm out of...
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna get this guy.
Oh.
I'm gonna take him home.
Can I take him home?
Oh he's dead.
Just kidding.
I should put my rations.
Grenade!
I fucked up!
Where did it go?
Is that it all the way over there?
Yeah I got it!
I didn't even notice that guy.
Yummy!
Wait I can take them home!
I'm taking them home.
Taking them home.
Thank you!
Where did the helicopter get in here?
Oh that's me taking them home.
Okay.
Oh I think I missed.
Maybe I didn't miss.
Maybe I'm so good!
I think I...
I missed.
Where are you throwing?
I'm just throwing.
We did it everybody!
Oh my goodness.
That was so stupid.
That was so silly.
I don't think I did really anything.
All good though.
That's not so bad.
Yay!
Curry recipe!
Alright let's go.
6, 4, 7, 9, 9?
Was that it?
6, 4, 7, 9...
6, 4, 7, 7, 9!
That was close.
That was actually close.
Awesome.
I screamed when the train rolled on top of all of us.
That was so funny!
Thank you Jesse!
Maybe?
The Basilisk!
Weirder things have happened Snake.
I'm just saying.
Maybe he hasn't seen all of the freaky things that have happened so far.
Aww yeah!
Blow it up!
I said thank you for the Akasupa earlier, but thank you!
I was like mid everything so...
I couldn't properly thank you, but thank you so much for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Wait, I didn't get to read the message completely either.
Happy to catch you midstream live!
Your voice and cute mannerisms keep me going!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you, thank you!
Mother Base!
You were mid.
Now we can trade!
Trade with other players.
Wait!
Can I now get your...
Minky!
Your gifts?
Inbox!
It's ok.
I'm not even a little sad.
I'm fine.
I'm ok.
I actually might...
stop here though.
We got through 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
7 missions.
Not bad.
Might call it here.
Is your Xbox in the correct time and date?
Yeah!
Because it literally said...
3.15 earlier.
I saw it.
It showed the date.
It said the date.
Thank you, Minto.
Letting me help you, glad to have made my part.
Best regards from KFP of the Romance Empire.
Thank you, Mobius!
Thank you.
But no, it said...
Next time though that we play, I do want to do...
some of the extra ops.
Do some of the extra ops and...
And then of course we'll do more missions.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did I get all the R&D things that I wanted to do?
OK, those are still...I think...
Yeah!
I like that.
C4.
Oh, it did get developed.
OK, good, good, good.
Good, good, good, good, good.
Good, good, good, good.
Gonna meet best character next stream.
I was thinking, I was just like...
Oh man, we're gonna have to meet that guy.
It's gonna ruin my day.
Thanks for the stream!
I love you, Sabine Walker.
Wisps and Frontiers forever.
Thank you!
Oh, he's great.
That guy, what does that mean?
You'll just have to find out!
Next stream!
That guy is coming up!
No one is ready.
Not as bad as Naomi.
Yeah, Naomi is worse.
Who am I kidding?
Thank you for the stream.
Now, Miller, roll the ads.
Do you like burgers?
Do you like hot dogs and burgers?
Join Wisps and Frontiers!
We've got burgers!
We've got hot dogs!
We've got espionage!
And...and on...and on Thursdays, we have bingo night!
Spank!
Thank you so much for the 20k!
Thank you!
Fries.
Well, when we get more people, we'll also have fries.
So join!
Join!
Thank you so much for playing with me, guys!
And yeah, this is so much fun.
I love Peace Walker.
We're not even into the meat of anything yet, so...
The story is gonna get so good!
We're gonna get into a lot of it next time, so...
Thank you for the gifted!
Thank you!
Yeah, we're gonna get into the real meat of the story next time, and all the mystery and interesting stuff.
But we did get to see, like, what the heck was the... Why did we hear the boss's voice?
And what the heck is Hatsune Miku flying around for?
And...
What are they doing with all the nukes, huh?
Jace, thank you!
Thank you for everything you do.
Your streams always cheer me up.
Thanks for the stream!
Thank you, Jace!
I hope you never change your profile picture.
Thank you so much for the stream, Mito.
Have fun with friends.
Have a great night.
You too, SPM!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
If it is the boss, I'm gonna cry.
We'll have to see.
We killed her, though.
We killed her, no?
Do you guys like this version?
It's kind of funny with my socks on, but...
Yeah, we'll go like this.
You guys like?
It's a very sneaking suit, no?
I thought it went well with Metal Gear.
Intimidating?
Not intimidating.
Spooky.
Scary.
And then my darker hair, which looks so funny with the bandana on.
OK,
OK.
Otsumito, everybody!
Otsumito, Otsumito.
I will see you guys next time.
Or whenever I see you next.
Bye-bye!
Itterasshai.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye!
Thank you!
See you!
Bye-bye!